le ministre des affaires étrangères
russe sergueï lavrov a prononcé deux
discours l'un à la conférence de
désarmement et le second au conseil des
droits de l'homme alors concernant la
conférence de désarmement il a précisé
deux objectifs l'un c'est la limitation
de la course aux armements spatiaux sur
la base d'un projet de traité élaboré
avec la chine est le second c'est
l'élaboration d'une convention
internationale pour lutter contre les
actes de terrorisme biologique et
chimique
mais surtout il a mené une lourde charge
contre washington
il accuse les etats-unis de se détourner
des efforts communs de tous les états
pour enrayer la course aux armements
pour preuve il a rappelé que les états
unis s'étaient retirés de nombreux
traités ou alors ne souhaitait pas les
renouveler et ce malgré les propositions
de la russie
donc il ya évidemment le traité start ou
encore le traité est fini je vous
propose de l'écouter à ce sujet nous
voyons aujourd'hui de manifestations
d'agression et d'égocentrisme de la part
d'un pays et le retrait de washington en
2002 de traité abm qui était très
important a été un coup porté à tous à
l'ensemble de la construction dans le
domaine de la maîtrise des armements et
ces derniers temps la politique des
américains se manifeste dans une volonté
d'ingérence partout et d'imposer selon
son intérêt à l'ensemble de la commune
et internationales en juin infraction au
droit international le retrait
unilatéral des états unis de l'accord
est finie suscite une grande inquiétude
pour l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
mais la russie en déclarant qu'elle sera
obligé de répondre par la réciproque au
déploiement d'armes américaine prend
l'engagement de ne pas développer ces
armements basés au sol tant qu il n'y
aura pas de l'équivalent américain nous
propose aux américains et
leur année 1 du moratoire analogues et
j'en profite pour rappeler que il faut
dissiper les soupçons qui répondent
actuellement nous sommes pour un régime
de vérification mutuelle
sayah lavrov s'est ensuite exprimé au
pupitre du conseil des droits de l'homme
devant lequel je me trouve
il a tout d'abord dénoncé ce qu'il
estime être un double standard des
démocraties occidentales en matière de
droits de l'homme et la citant en
exemple l'ukraine selon lui à des
minorités ils seraient bafoués également
les pays baltes ou des groupuscules néo
nazi et xénophobe re surgir est et cela
dans l'indifférence des nations
occidentales
mais il faut aussi noter que diverses
personnalités ici on dénonçait la
situation en syrie à idleb et à cela ça
y est la preuve a répliqué qu'il fallait
combattre le terrorisme et ne pas
capituler
d'ailleurs en parlant de terrorisme
sergueï lavrov a estimé que son
expansion était due à une crise
migratoire sans précédent une crise que
les états devraient s'engager à résoudre
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir des discours
aujourd'hui de sergueï lavrov à genève